well one thing I've always liked about
your anime videos and your just videos
about reviewing media in general is that
you always come through it with the like
a such a like a different lens from like
how like hardcore fan bases would view
it like if I see if I see review and
Anime I know I'm not just I'm not just
gonna get an anime Fan's perspective but
someone who just likes media in general
you know and I think uh you know I think
I think that's something that's really
really missing in the anime community in
fact because so many people in anime for
the longest time if you're an anime fan
you are nothing but an anime fan right
do you know what I mean you don't
consume any other medium yeah yeah right
and I think a lot of anime fans forget
especially anime is [ __ ] weird a lot
of the times I think we've just like I
think we've just just gotten used to a
lot of the weird [ __ ] that we can't like
even like pinpoint it yeah yeah right it
gets it gets a little wacky I agree I
I'm very tired of the Trope of
everyone's like a middle schooler when
it has no place in it Tokyo Revengers I
get is based off of the guys like actual
experience but why the [ __ ] are they
still middle schoolers they could have
been adults it literally like made the
show like two points worse yeah
absolutely just just because they
insisted on keeping them like 13.
there's no reason to like they're riding
motorcycles their parents aren't present
like there's no amazing all the time you
just look at the character designs
you're like you can't tell me he's a 14.
yeah there's literally yeah you
literally look like 27. seven foot gets
stabbed and lives and he's 14. [ __ ] off
no yeah but isn't it weird that we're
okay we're not okay with that when it
comes to something like Tokyo Avengers
but if it's something like Baki we're
like yeah
I think it was back he never asked you
to get invested in like a serious
emotional way God [ __ ] he's so good it's
Sparky [ __ ] insane I think we've been
saying we're like it if if only it
caught on a little bit more I could
easily be like that JoJo level of show
of like yeah they need to increase the
animation budget though I don't know if
you watch the recent ones it's like very
much like still images that they shake a
camera on yeah yeah if you they got like
JoJo's level of Animation I swear would
be like as popular oh I think yeah
Becky's done weird as [ __ ] than Jojo
what embarrassing yeah in like I just
love that Becky will do the stupidest
[ __ ] but it will deliver it to you in
the most serious narration it'll be like
this oh my God just just the fact that
he literally Powers up after he loses
that's the best thing in the world how
is that not like the most iconic scene
and his dad's just like seen this
okay yes that whole season was amazing I
I can't remember the big Mafia guy's
name but he comes up to him
they're at the river and he comes up
he's like your girlfriend does she want
to be a prostitute or something
well no I don't I don't think so and
then she's like getting really serious
like oh my God Baki like maybe I will
it's like such a weird scene I remember
watching that I was like this this is
amazing like this is absolutely amazing
and everyone forgets he's 14. it's like
eight feet tall it gets revived yeah I'm
drinking at like 10 liters of sugar
water did you say Japanese YouTuber try
to do it yeah yeah yeah yeah so have you
have you seen the the scene in Bucky I
think it's the second season yeah where
like he gets like poisoned or whatever
and he like gets really really skinny oh
yeah that was after the slapping guy
right yeah yeah yeah and then dead
zukayo it gets like all right I know how
to revive him and he gets this like 10
liter bucket of water and 10 kilograms
of sugar and he's like drink it and it
somehow revives and then it somehow
revives him and I saw this Japanese
YouTube it was like I wonder if you you
can do that in real life and so he
literally got like a bucket of water 10
liters put 10 kilograms of sugar in it
and started drinking it he maybe got
like one 50th of the way and just like
he's like can't confirm it does not work
in real life it just gives you diabetes
instant diabetes
oh my God yeah I noticed you do a lot of
like okay let's talk about Moby huge for
a second how did how did that become
like a meme I saw it on Amazon you saw
it on Amazon
wait wait what do you mean you still
just see that on Amazon well because
they give you like the recommended based
on things you bought and like I bought
dildos before usually from Adam and Eve
but Amazon had some weird stuff so I
bought from there they recommended Moby
huge at some point I was like wow that's
kind of nuts it turns out FaZe jev had
had one at some point so then I got to
see it in his video before ordering I
was like that's pretty good yeah yeah so
then 600 later got a Moby huge never
looked back it's great I gotta ask why
did you go through a phase of buying
dildo yeah so I I'm like oh I mean no
one you know no one else was brave
enough to test like what are they
capable of besides just like putting
them in your butthole like I needed to
see you know can we make a car out of it
yeah can we hit pinatas with it you know
like I had to test it I think that's why
people really enjoy your stuff it's like
you ask the questions that no one wanted
answers too afraid to answer yeah maybe
maybe even that yeah maybe that's a
better way of phrasing it yeah have you
ever thought about buying some of like
the weird [ __ ] from Japan because
there's a lot of [ __ ] we bought an RV
positor I don't think it was from Japan
though but that's the egg or what oh you
guys don't know what I'll be positives
hey no it's a uh so it's like a pseudo
dildo but it's really spongy and
flexible and it's like an alien weiner
but it has egg inserts so you can push
like a lubed egg through so when you
insert it you can put eggs into yourself
which is pretty cool so we got those
we got three we got it
do you remember what they were called
Danny I'm sorry to bring you in like
this but they had cool names it was like
the shakishu was
yeah the shakusha was like the long
morning this is like a fetish the floor
the floor was the great one
until like the egg thing the the Avi
positor Community there's a community
was dishonest about the the floor but
yeah
exposing
oh my God those were so cool and they
were great yeah so but like speaking of
which like you know including the Moby
Dick and everything I'm not Moby Dick
maybe huge like you what upload what
twice a day usually yeah but one of them
is usually just stream highlights yeah
whether I'm playing a game or going over
like a goofy topic and then the other
one will be a video I sit down like yeah
so like one one question I want to ask
like just as a fellow content creator is
how do you not get burned out I think
it's just from doing different things
there was absolutely a time like just
doing game playing commentary I'm like
this is getting kind of this he's still
not doing Halo right I started it back
like initially I started in 07 and it
was Gears of War all right so those were
the first videos I like made myself
seven yeah and then I it was Gears of
War then I transitioned Gears of War to
Halo then around 2010 I started doing
fun tactics for Battlefield which was
the first commentaries and then from
there gameplay commentaries that you
know always fun but started to get a
little also then started doing like
infomercial dubs I remember the
information about yeah so I just always
kept trying to spend new content to keep
it fresh I feel like if you stay in one
Niche for too long it gets a little
stale for you yeah yeah exactly yeah
definitely been there I mean his name's
the anime man and he doesn't watch anime
anymore so I haven't made anime content
like over a year yeah but I think that's
the way to do it though right like you
don't want to force yourself to make
something no because it's not fun for
the audience it's not fun it's new
absolutely but why two videos a day I I
just have a lot do you feel like [ __ ] I
really want to make this video but I
just don't have time to invest into it
no I always have plenty of time to do
stuff like if it's a bigger project
always make sure to allocate time
if there's one thing I want to see you
make a video on uh It's featured in one
of Joey's video but you know what Tango
is yeah yeah so there's this Tenga that
it's basically like an Iron Maiden oh my
gosh that is basically like how how
heavy was it again it's uh 15 kilograms
so it's like what 25 30 pounds 30 pounds
yeah yeah and it's basically it's it's
like it's like yeah like a steel case
for your Tango and the sole purpose of
it is so that you can work out while you
jack yeah
so it's like a shake weight almost yeah
but like if you dropped it it would
probably
yeah destroy your days
like Tenga has like so many like like I
did a video with gone where we tested
out like all the Tangers that they have
at the Tanga headquarters and they have
so many women they have a vending
machine for him now don't they yeah yeah
yeah they have like mechs so like they
have the tango and it transforms into
like a Mac yeah it's like it's like it's
like a tank I don't I don't know but you
can't actually [ __ ] the Tango it's just
it's just like a toy that is in the
shape of a Tango that can turn into a
Mac I don't know why Japan is just you
know he's just one of those companies
where it's just like should we make it
yeah yeah the answer is yes yeah the
answer is yeah
and I can respect that I can respect
absolutely absolutely no what's
something like the weirdest Contraptions
you've like found because your dad makes
some weird Contraptions yeah so you've
shown that are in your studio right now
yeah so he's my dad likes to make goofy
stuff so he made the Moby huge into the
go-kart you guys saw that yeah he's made
the automatic ass wiping robot which it
doesn't work it just like peels your ass
off how does that work so you got a
rotating motor and he put like like a
scrubber on it so instead of toilet
paper just like a scrubber to scrub your
ass but it goes so fast that you can't
use it you'd hurt yourself I just feel
like a bidet solves this yeah it does it
just for the joke of it he doesn't
actually want to use them he's like son
I just I just think uh yeah a few more
iterations I think it might be too it'll
work I think he should rename it to the
hammerward machine it's probably the one
thing you just shave like pieces of your
asses
like your ass too fat all right get on
that thing man I'll just shave some off
I don't know what the weirdest thing
I've ever seen would be though I'd have
to really think was there one thing
where you looked at and you're like this
is too weird to turn into a video yeah
uh so we it wasn't in the back building
I don't know if we got rid of it we had
32 pounds of [ __ ] and ass it was this
hold on giant hold on pause okay
so there's a place a local chain called
the Todd which is just you know normal
sex shop but they had something called
32 pounds of [ __ ] and ass yeah and it's
just this giant ass and [ __ ] and our
idea was to do a toilet paper tearless
by smudging chocolate on it and wiping
it to see like which was the most
absorbent it was Danny's idea and we
couldn't do it because the [ __ ] and ass
are like it's too fat like you can't
actually show it do you have this here I
think it's still there I don't know
right it's too dummy okay could you with
your hands it's this big it's like like
it would sit in your lap comfortably
it's it's big it's gelatinous it Jiggles
in there it makes cool noises like when
you slap it purchase it oh it's like 80
bucks 80 bucks
was it what am I thinking of for 80 we
definitely
some motherfucked up thing especially
going to the store you just like [ __ ]
negotiating it like yeah the best I can
do best I can do is 10 times 12 is going
to buy 32 pounds
I'll take six Ruby hugees right now with
20 discount I'll get them out of your
store I'll take your entire stuff
all the sex children know you by name
locally yeah oh [ __ ] here he comes is
this just the [ __ ] that happens in
Florida yeah I mean I'm sure the Todd
sells plenty they have lower ones like
if lower models they have 20 pounds of
[ __ ] and ass they have 10. like you
know they have full medium large yeah
they have sizes but yeah I don't think
anyone's going to the Wombo like so
whether this obsession with like the sex
toy stop just because it just seemed fun
just because no one else was really
getting puffy with it I thought it'd
just be a fun fact I mean you know
YouTube normally would crack down yeah
that kind of content get like age some
of it does some of it doesn't even get
demonetized but some of it does get age
restricted if you get like really
egregious one of the YouTube algorithm
just thinks these items are I don't know
like they're throwing a small child
around yeah
I'd love to know what the machine is
analyzing it it's like yeah well that's
a that's half a human yeah they
definitely don't register it as a wiener
why would you shoot oh my God